les personnels soignants non vaccinés
vont pouvoir réintégrer les hôpitaux ou
les EHPAD c'est l'annonce faite par le
Ministre de la Santé en début de semaine
cela représenterait 4000 professionnels
selon la Fédération hospitalière de
France au CHRU de Tours 12 personnes
sont concernées des fonctionnaires
suspendus depuis le 15 septembre 2021
même si la date officielle de leur
retour n'est pas connue dans les
couloirs de l'hôpital tour en jour on
s'y prépare Sarah gros
ils étaient une cinquantaine de
soignants a refuser la piqûre contre le
coronavirus le nombre avis diminué dès
le 15 septembre 2021 lorsqu'il a été
annoncé que le personnel non vacciné
serait suspendu une douzaine de
personnes sont encore concernées la
nouvelle ne semble pas déranger les
tours enjaux le coït étant moins sévère
que ce qu'il était je trouve ça un petit
peu aberrant dans le contexte où il y a
plus assez soignants de l'hôpital de de
mettre à l'écart certains patients
certains soignants avec le masque déjà
on risque moins mais donc j'ai confiance
selon les services je peux comprendre le
la nécessité de réintégrer
mais c'est pas forcément quelque chose
qui à sa place dans tous les services et
selon la présidente du Collectif 37
notre santé en danger certains se hâte
de remettre leur blues aujourd'hui ne
demande qu'à retourner travailler donc
c'est vrai que dans le contexte actuel
où la crise covid est quand même bien
bien calmé
on peut que se satisfaire de de que ces
gens-là puissent retourner au travail
dans les conditions actuelles de manque
de personnel la décision satisfait aussi
la direction de l'hôpital de Tours qui
désire renforcer ses effectifs mais il
s'agit avant tout de renouer avec le
personnel concerné on est aussi là pour
porter le discours que un on va prendre
contact avec eux que deux on a besoin
d'eux et que 3 l'ensemble des équipes me
feront attention à ce que la
réintégration se passe bien est-ce que
cette position qu'ils avaient le droit
de prendre ne le reçois pas reproché
mais pour autant on continue dans un
contexte où l'épidémie potentiellement
continue à reprendre encore une fois
parce que évidemment les gestes
barrières soient repris et puis en
portant le message aussi que évidemment
le vaccination est un des moyens parmi
d'autres de lutter contre la propagation
de l'épidémie la suspension n'a pas été
sans conséquence pour les soignants non
vaccinés car faute d'emploi ces
fonctionnaires n'ont touché ni salaire
ni chômage certains ont même été
contraints de se tourner vers un autre
travail désormais les soignants désireux
de réintégrer les effectifs devront
attendre l'approbation du gouvernement